corona virus in deutschland mindestens
fünf weitere menschen infizieren sich
der bundesgesundheitsminister erwartet
eine deutlich stärkere verbreitung bei
uns dieses urteil fordert gesellschaft
und politik das bundesverfassungsgericht
sagt jeder mensch soll frei entscheiden
dürfen wann und wie er stirbt und
führungskrise und standortsuche beim
politischen aschermittwoch dreht sich
bei der union
hauptsächlich um die union
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers sonnabend in allen an
diesem aschermittwoch hier ist der
überblick über den nachrichten tag sport
nachher in der sendung mit kristin otto
hallo und genannt wir müssen auch heute
beginnen mit dem kampf gegen das corona
virus erfolgt eine nachricht auf die
nächste heute das virus verbreitet sich
weiter auch und gerade in europa die
situation ändert sich permanent und sie
ist zunehmend unübersichtlich der
bundesgesundheitsminister sagt heute
abend die infektionsketten seien
teilweise nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen
und deswegen sei es fraglich ob die
bisherige strategie zum eingrenzen des
virus und zum beenden der
infektionsketten weiter aufgehe
hier ist der aktuelle stand zunächst in
deutschland zu den 16 fällen der
vergangenen wochen sind einzelne dazu
gekommen und zwar vier in baden
württemberg eine infektion in göppingen
2 in tübingen eine in rottweil und zwei
corona fälle gibt es im kreis heinsberg
in nordrhein westfalen ein ehepaar wie
das virus weiter um sich greift und
welche schwierigkeiten im kampf dagegen
auftreten berichtet christoph distel
eine schule im kreis heinsberg
sicherheitshalber geschlossen wie auch
andere in der gegend als so ernst gilt
die lage
obwohl kein schüler jedes virus hatte
nur ein mann der in der nähe lebte und
arbeitete
und der jetzt hier liegt in der
uniklinik düsseldorf mit symptomen einer
schweren lungenentzündung meldete sich
der 47 jährige erst in einem anderen
krankenhaus landete dann schnell auf der
intensivstation dort kam es zu einer
raschen und rapiden verschlechterung des
allgemeinzustandes es kam zu einem
lungen versagen cupid 19 mit dieser
diagnose kommt er nach düsseldorf die
ehefrau auch infiziert immerhin über
nacht wird es nicht schlimmer
gleichzeitig aber wird den politisch
verantwortlichen klar was dieses
ereignis bedeutet wir befinden uns am
beginn einer krone epidemie in
deutschland und die infektionsketten
sind teilweise und das ist die neue
qualität nicht nachzuvollziehen
es gibt eine vielzahl von personen die
mit den erkrankten kontakt hatten heißt
konkret dass jetzt in der klinik
isolierte paar hatte vorher noch keiner
mal gefeiert er freiberufler sie
kindergärtnerin waren sie außerdem bei
mehreren ärzten sogar auf kurzurlaub in
holland jede menge kontaktpersonen
verdachtsfälle sind deswegen bereits in
häuslicher quarantäne etwas
überschaubarer dagegen der zweite corona
fall heute göppingen bei stuttgart ein
25 jähriger hatte sich nach italien
urlaub schlecht gefühlt und alles
richtig gemacht sich sofort beim
gesundheitsamt gemeldet und sofort wurde
er isoliert trotzdem 13 sozialkontakte
hatte er vorher familie freunde
auch sie sind jetzt alle in häuslicher
isolation außer seiner freundin und
deren vater
beide liegen in dieser klinik in
tübingen bei ihnen ergaben die tests
auch infiziert der vater ist oberarzt an
einer uniklinik dort oft aber ist an der
uniklinik in düsseldorf dort guten abend
bleiben wir vielleicht erst mal bei den
aktuell bestätigten fällen in nordrhein
westfalen
wenn wir gerade den
bundesgesundheitsminister gehört haben
können den krankenhaus und behörden
überhaupt noch erreichen dass nicht
weitere menschen infiziert werden
zunächst einmal geht man hier in dem
düsseldorfer universitätsklinikum sehr
routiniert mit den fällen um die liegen
auf der isolierstation nicht auf der
sonder isolierstation die beispielsweise
für fälle wie ebola vorbehalten ist
sondern auf einer ganz normalen und das
bedeutet auch dass herkömmliche
krankenhäuser ebenfalls gewappnet wären
für den umgang mit eventuellen patienten
man versucht jetzt weiter die
zahlreichen kontaktpersonen dieses
erkrankten ehepaares ausfindig zu machen
zu testen
daneben aufzufordern sich in häuslicher
quarantäne aufzuhalten und es gibt die
aufforderung sich nicht mehr an
massenveranstaltungen zu beteiligen das
öffentliche leben in diesem kreis liegt
ja weitgehend flach also bibliotheken
geschlossen schwimmbäder geschlossen und
so weiter das bedeutet man appelliert an
die eigenverantwortung an den
selbstschutz der bürger weil man eben
diese infektionskette wenn nicht schon
unterbrechen dann möglichst verlangsamen
möchte roter farbe herzlichen dank live
in düsseldorf
es gibt noch viele fragen im
zusammenhang mit dem virus die offen
sind und erstmal offen bleiben werden
auch daran müssen wir uns gewöhnen
dennoch kann man sich vorbereiten der
staat und jeder einzelne auch welche
pläne es dazu in deutschland gibt dazu
antoine kurschilgen
immer mehr corona fälle in deutschland
der gesundheitsminister reagiert und
weist die krankenhäuser an sich auf die
neue lage einzustellen
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass diese
epidemie an deutschland vorbei geht wird
sich nicht erfüllen und nicht ergeben
aus diesem grund habe ich heute in einer
telefonkonferenz mit den
gesundheitsministern der länder diese
gebeten ihre vorhandenen landes
pandemiepläne soweit noch nicht
geschehen zu aktualisieren konkret heißt
das krankenhäuser wie die uniklinik
frankfurt bereiten sich vor auf die
behandlung von mehr corona patienten und
benötigen dafür mehr schutzanzüge und
mehr isolierstationen bislang gibt es
kein medikament gegen die neurologen
krankheit das will die uni-klinik ändern
wir fangen jetzt auch an ganz bestimmte
medikamente oder substanzen zu
untersuchen ob es da eine antivirale
wirkung gibt die man dann später
therapeutisch einsetzen könnte auch
jeder einzelne kann etwas tun um das
virus einzudämmen häufig und gründlich
hände waschen was banal klingt sehr
wichtig betonen experten der
grippeähnliche symptome aufweist und
angst hat es könnte kroner sein sollte
folgendes tun
wichtigste ist erst mal seinen hausarzt
anzurufen und nicht gleich zum hausarzt
zu gehen und dort mit dem erstmal
rücksprache zu halten die das weitere
vorgehen ist wenn es jetzt eine milde
symptomatik ist dann kann der hausarzt
selber einen abstrich machen und zum
beispiel zu uns mit überweisungsschein
die probe schicken und wir können es auf
corona virus testen
eine impfung gegen das neue corona virus
gibt es bislang nicht und es wird wohl
auch noch bis ende des jahres dauern bis
ein impfstoff zur verfügung steht der
ganzen welt breitet sich das virus immer
weiter aus mehr als 81.000 infektionen
meldet die weltgesundheitsorganisation
und auch europa zählt immer mehr fälle
am stärksten betroffen weiter italien wo
das virus bei mindestens 370 menschen
nachgewiesen wurde
zwölf patienten sind gestorben auch die
schweiz und österreich melden corona
fälle und in frankreich gibt es zwei
tote
in einem hotel auf teneriffa stehen
weiter rund 1000 menschen unter
quarantäne
viele von ihnen sind deutsche es gibt
ständig neue nachrichten rund um das
virus auf heute.de halten wir sie in
einem live blog auf dem laufenden
und außerdem dort praktische hinweise
was jeder einzelne tun kann um sich zu
schützen so viel zunächst dazu jetzt zu
ganz schwierigen juristischen fragen an
der grenze von leben und tod
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat heute
ein wegweisendes urteil gefällt zur
sterbehilfe
die richter kippten den
strafrechtsparagrafen 217 der die
beihilfe zur selbsttötung verboten hatte
nur in seltenen ausnahmefällen war es
bisher erlaubt einem sterbewilligen
tödliche medikamente bereitzustellen
heute sagte das bundesverfassungsgericht
das verbot verstößt gegen die
grundrechte der mensch habe ein recht
auf selbstbestimmtes sterben
günther neufeld helmut feldmann hat eine
unheilbare lungenkrankheit noch bekommt
der luft doch er weiß nicht wie lange
noch wenn man auch therapiert es gibt es
keine hilfe mehr
und dann erstickt man qualvoll
er möchte ein medikament das in
friedlich einschlafen lässt wenn er es
nicht mehr aushält weil er das in
deutschland nicht bekommt zog er vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht gemeinsam mit
anderen patienten mit ärzten und
sterbehilfe organisationen
es geht um paragraf 217 strafgesetzbuch
förderung der selbsttötung einem
sterbewilligen ein tödliches mittel
beschaffen bisher war das praktisch
verboten das aber geht dem gericht zu
weit jeder mensch habe ein recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben
dieses recht schließt die freiheit ein
sich das leben zu nehmen hierfür bei
dritten hilfe zu suchen und soweit sie
angeboten wird in anspruch zu nehmen
das bedeutet ab sofort dürfen mediziner
angehörige und sterbehilfeorganisationen
tödliche medikamente beschaffen wenn
sterbewillige das wünschen für die ärzte
die in karlsruhe geklagt haben ein sieg
auf ganzer linie
große erleichterung vor allen dingen
deswegen weil wir mit den patienten
offen und frei sprechen können ohne
irgendwelche belastungen durch das
existierende gesetz der bundestag kam
die beihilfe zur selbsttötung neu regeln
komplett verbieten darf er sie nicht
gegner der sterbehilfe sehen das
kritisch ich befürchte dass es eine
gesellschaftliche tendenz befördern kann
der gewöhnung an suizidhilfe als
behandlungs variante das hielt die ich
für verhängnisvoll helmut feldmann
verfolgt die urteilsverkündung zu hause
vor dem fernseher
er ist zu tränen gerührt als sie die
entscheidenden sätze hört ich werde sehr
gelassen wieder sein das weiß ich durch
dieses urteil
die angst vor einem qualvollen sterben
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat sie ihm
genommen
ja das ist ein historisches urteil dass
sowohl für befürworter als auch für
kritiker an die grundfesten geht da
sieht man an den reaktionen heute schon
ganz alleine aus unserer rechts
redaktion ist sehr attacke im studio
sarah guten abend jetzt müssen wir
zunächst vielleicht mal eins klarstellen
das gilt nicht nur für schwerstkranke
das gilt für uns alle ganz genau mit dem
urteil heute seit heute hat jeder den
anspruch selbstbestimmt zu sterben
suizidhilfe in anspruch zu nehmen und
das gilt eben nicht nur für
schwerstkranke sondern auch für
kerngesunde man muss bei verstand sein
das heißt nicht dement krank sein aber
dieser anspruch hat mit dem tag heute
jeder
aber das heißt ja dass jetzt auch leuten
erstmal toren tür geöffnet sind die
diese beihilfe zur selbsttötung anbieten
und damit möglicherweise sogar geld
verdienen wollen ganz genau die grenze
des anspruchs auch das haben die richter
und richter ganz deutlich gesagt liegt
im gegenüber man muss jemanden finden
der bereit ist hilfe zum suizid zu
leisten kein arzt ist verpflichtet das
zu tun
ähnlich wie beim schwangerschaftsabbruch
man muss bereit sein das zu tun
da aber die berufsordnung der ärzte in
vielen bundesländern in den aller
meisten bundesländern sogar es ärzten
verbietet aktuell beihilfe zum suizid zu
leisten sie riskieren damit ihre
approbation damit das überhaupt als arzt
arbeiten können ist natürlich vor allem
die beihilfe zum suizid den geöffnet die
bereits und das zu tun und das können
natürlich vor allem sterbehilfe vereine
sein und diejenigen die damit geld
verdienen wolle
denn mit dem tag heute es ist völlig
frei jeder kann hilfe zum suizid leisten
und jeder hat einen anspruch darauf dass
heißt es ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass wir
alle regeln uns aufstellen und regeln
selbst geben und zwar nicht nur die
regierung sondern die gesamte
gesellschaft darüber erst mal diskutiert
ganz genau dieses urteil ist ganz klar
als aufruf zu verstehen als an uns als
gesellschaft und an die politik tätig zu
werden wir müssen uns überlegen das
recht auf selbstbestimmte sterben steht
im grundgesetz dass es jetzt abgeleitet
das steht fest aber welche regeln waren
wir drum herum soll man auf seite eins
an der zeitung werben können bei uns
günstig und gut sterben wollen wir
vermutlich nicht aber dafür müssen wir
regeln schaffen deswegen ist das ganze
ein aufruf an uns angetan die
gesellschaft und an die politik ein ganz
entscheidender tag mit folgen der
attacke vielen dank für diese
erläuterung heute abend und jetzt
anderes thema zum politischen
aschermittwoch da heißt es ja jedes jahr
jeder gegen jeden in diesem jahr hieß es
vor allem alle gegen rechts die parteien
bis auf die afd warnten vor
rechtsextremismus und rassismus anderes
großes thema die führungskrise in der
cdu die ersten kandidaten für den
parteivorsitz stehen ja fest der
wahlkampf ist eröffnet patricia schäfer
berichtet was das spitzenpersonal der
union in eigener sache zu sagen hat die
klarste ansage zur kandidatenkür kam von
csu chef markus söder in sachen
kanzlerkandidat bekräftigte er seinen
anspruch auf mitbestimmung geben und
ohne die stimme aus bayern kann kein
unionsmann gewählt werden also geht es
nur mit uns gemeint haben liebe freunde
das ist die klare forderung aber wer
soll es denn nun werden stimmen aus dem
saal
[Musik]
meiner meinung nach der besseren kann
man nämlich den söder in bayern geholfen
der aschermittwoch diesmal auch ein
schaulaufen der bewerber um den
cdu-vorsitz friedrich merz ist dem
thüringen zu gast seine
aschermittwochsrede wird jedoch erst
später erwartet
armin laschet blieb daheim in
nordrhein-westfalen bewegte sich
bekannterweise ins hochsauerland den
heimatkreis von friedrich merz einen
appell zur geschlossenheit in dieser
schwierigen zeit wo wir bei den umfragen
nicht die besten werte haben wo wir
merken das wenn wir nicht aufpassen wir
in eine ähnliche krise geraten können
wie die spd das werden wir nur schaffen
wenn alle mit an bord sind die
scheidende cdu chefin annegret kramp
karrenbauer war am vormittag in baden
württemberg am abend in mecklenburg
vorpommern für die cdu muss klar sein
der politische gegner ist immer
außerhalb der partei und nicht in den
eigenen reihen auch daran darf es keins
weise geht die union versucht heute in
zeiten des wettbewerbs dem zusammenhalt
zu wahren
seine tat am rosenmontag hat deutschland
geschockt jetzt ist gegen den
tatverdächtigen autofahrer aus
volkmarsen haftbefehl erlassen worden
ihm werden versuchter mord und
gefährliche körperverletzung vorgeworfen
der 29-jährige war vorgestern in einem
karnevalsumzug gefahren mehr als 60
menschen wurden dabei verletzt darunter
20 kinder
warum der mann in die menschenmenge vor
dazu äußert er sich bislang nicht ganz
anderes thema windenergie da erlebt
deutschland zwar zweite einen ziemlichen
stillstand von wirtschaftsminister peter
altmaier kommt jetzt ein neuer vorschlag
zu den bauvorschriften die regel dass
windräder mindestens 1000 meter von
häusern entfernt sein müssen würde
danach aufgeweicht dass sollen dann die
bundesländer selbst entscheiden
um das ziel 65 prozent erneuerbare
energien bis 2030 noch zu erreichen
gute nachrichten für opel der autobauer
konnte im vergangenen jahr 1,1
milliarden euro gewinn
fahren die erfolgsnachricht kommt nach
zweieinhalb jahren hartem sparkurs
dabei sind seit der übernahme durch den
französischen konzern psa tausende
arbeitsplätze weggefallen
vom gewinn gehen jetzt noch steuern
zinsen und kosten für die
restrukturierung weg dennoch zahlt opel
seinen mitarbeitern zum ersten mal seit
1997 einen bonus und damit sind wir bei
kristin und dem sport genau zweimal
fußball zuerst die hiobsbotschaft für
den fc bayern münchen robert lewandowski
muss wegen einer knieverletzung vier
wochen pausieren
der torjäger hatte im gestrigen
achtelfinal hinspiel der champions
league beim fc chelsea das 13 0 erzielt
sein anteil am bayrischen frohsinn karl
heinz rummenigge überreichte hansi flick
nachträglich zum geburtstag ein geschenk
mit andeutung für die die nicht wissen
was da drin ist in dem roten päckchen
ist ein stift und mit stiften beim fc
bayern unterschreibt man manchmal auch
papiere 1 vertrags papier für flick über
die saison hinaus könnte da gemeint
gewesen sein
die bayern hatten zuvor ein meisterwerk
abgeliefert mit robert lewandowski und
sabri nach der pause schien ambri schon
im gruppenspiel bei tottenham viermal
erfolgreich glänzte mit zwei toren
diesmal auf der londoner bühne
lewandowski zum 13 und entstand auch
wieder mit einem treffer in einem
ko-spiel bei den champions das war eine
lehrstunde
das niveau wollen wir auch mal erreichen
das ist absolut gut kontrolliert und
natürlich ein 3 0 auswärts ergebnis also
ist natürlich ein schäumchen zum traum
wird es dann mit dem einzug ins
viertelfinale nach dem rückspiel
gut zwei wochen nach seinem
überraschenden rücktritt als trainer von
hertha bsc hat jürgen klinsmann den
bundesligavereinen eine art
generalabrechnung heftig attackiert die
hertha erwägt nun juristische schritte
die gegenwart alles andere als sonnig in
fußball berlin tobt eine mediale
schlammschlacht auslöser interner
aufzeichnungen von ex-trainer klinsmann
durchgestochen an ein sportmagazin der
manager setzt sich zur wehr
die angriffe weiß ich wirklich aufs
schärfste zurück das ist einfach nur
perfide das ist ungehörig die vorwürfe
klinsmanns deutlich er spricht der
vereinsführung die fähigkeit zum
sportlich fahren
wirklichen handeln ab der club wäre ohne
den trainerwechsel ende november direkt
abgestiegen weil er auf diese situation
gar nicht vorbereitet ist
unruhige zeiten in berlin die nahe
zukunft heißt abstiegskampf freitag muss
die hertha nach düsseldorf angespannte
lage
dann können uns jetzt alle gemeinsam
noch die lottozahlen anschauen
die gewinnzahlen lauten 25 18 33 45 47
und die superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7 thema winter
jetzt schnee hatten wir ja heute schon
morgen kommt nochmal was dann aber erst
am nachmittag alle details gleich von
katja honnefer um 21.45 empfehle ich
ihnen das heute journal mit dem kollegen
claus kleber von uns war es das für
heute vom gesamten team danke für ihr
interesse und in allen ein angenehmer
abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren die
spannenden winterwetter zeit dauern an
heute gab es ja schnee und über dem
atlantik dreht sie schon das nächste
schnee sturmtief bianca heute nacht gibt
es noch schneeschauer zum teil auch
kurze gewitter
das vor allen dingen auch im nordwesten
da ist es allerdings mehr regen sie
müssen sich allerdings überall auf
glatte straßen einstellen denn die
temperaturen sinken in dieser nacht auf
plus 2 bis minus 4 grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 0 grad in der eifel und 9 grad
am oberrhein und bereits am vormittag
beginnt es im saarland und in
rheinland-pfalz kräftig zu schneien
dieser schnee zieht dann im laufe des
nachmittags weiter nach osten habe ich
das südliche niedersachsen dem spessart
die rhön und auch das allgäu und dann
nimmt der wind böig zu er dreht von süd
westen auf westliche richtungen damit
geht der schneefall zunächst in regen
über und es drohen orkanartige sturmböen
in baden württemberg und bayern aber
auch in den mittelgebirgen müssen sie
auf jeden fall mit schneeverwehungen
rechnen und mit tief winterlichen
straßenverhältnissen und in den nächsten
tagen beruhigt sich das wetter zum
wochenende wird es deutlich milder mit
etwas regen
schönen abend noch